Niemals wäre ich auf den Gedanken
zukommen, mit jemanden sexuell mich
einzulassen, in der Hoffnung auf berufliche
Privilegien oder Vorteile.
Bei der MeToo-Bewegung geht
es ja eben nicht nur um ich, ich,
ich und meine individuellen
Erfahrungen, sondern einfach Empathie zu entwickeln
für Erfahrungen von ganz vielen Frauen,
die ja auch ihre Erlebnisse geteilt haben.
Herzlich willkommen bei 13 Fragen,
wir starten direkt mit der ersten Frage: Ist
nach fast fünf Jahren MeToo immer
noch alles beim Alten? Wenn ihr sagt ja,
wir stehen beim Kampf gegen Machtmissbrauch
immer noch so ziemlich
am Anfang, dann geht ihr jetzt bitte
auf das grüne Feld. Und wenn ihr sagt nein,
eigentlich hat sich durch MeToo schon
ziemlich viel verändert, einiges zum Guten
und anderes vielleicht sogar zum Nachteil,
dann könnt ihr jetzt auf das gelbe Feld
gehen. Ihr könnt euch jetzt
gerne positionieren. Jetzt wissen wir,
wo meine Gäste stehen, aber wo würdet
ihr dann auf dem Feld stehen?
Sexuelle Übergriffe,
Machtmissbrauch, Sexismus am Arbeitsplatz.
Das millionenfach genutzte Hashtag
MeToo sollte weltweit die Erfahrung von Frauen
sichtbar machen. Den Anfang machten
2017 die Enthüllungen um den Hollywood
Produzenten Harvey Weinstein in den USA.
Und auch wenn die Debatte zwar schnell
hier in Deutschland gelandet ist,
häuften sich die Fälle erst so richtig im letzten
Jahr. Der ehemalige Chefredakteur
der Bild, Julian Reichelt, Comedy Star,
Luke Mockridge und der ehemalige
Intendant der Berliner Volksbühne, Klaus Dörr,
all sie verloren ihre Jobs aufgrund von MeToo-Vorwürfen
oder mussten sie zumindest
pausieren. Und auch in der Musikbranche
sorgte das Hashtag #deutschrapmetoo
für heftige Diskussionen. Sind wir also
noch ganz am Anfang? Unsere Gäste sind
sich uneinig, aber wir suchen hier bei 13
Fragen ja ein Kompromiss. Deswegen bin
ich gespannt ob die beiden Seiten,
sich zumindest ein bisschen heute aufeinander
zubewegen werden und ob sie sich
auch auf die eine oder andere Errungenschaft
aus den letzten fünf Jahren dann
doch einigen können. Aber jetzt erst mal
an euch auf welcher Seite würdet ihr denn
stehen? Sagt ihr wie die grüne Seite
eigentlich ist alles noch beim Alten
oder wie die Gelben, nö, es hat sich schon
ziemlich viel getan. Schreibt
es mir in die Kommentare. Ab jetzt,
wenn ihr ein Argument der anderen
Seite zustimmt, dann bewegt ihr euch einen
Schritt nach vorne. Und wenn ihr vielleicht
auch während eine andere Person
spricht, das zum Ausdruck bringen
wollt, dass ihr das ganz anders sehen oder wütend
seid, dann könnt ihr euch einen
Schritt nach hinten bewegen. Caro, du hast
zu Beginn deiner beruflichen Laufbahn
bei Axel Springer angefangen und hast direkt
dort Machtmissbrauch
erlebt. In welcher Weise?
Das ging von SMS, E-Mails, damals gab
es noch viel Facebook. Ich bin teilweise
auch über Jahre mit dem Chefredakteur
essen gegangen, freitags, weil man wurde
dazu aufgefordert, er wollte sich
blicken lassen in den schönen Restaurants
der Stadt und wollte natürlich hübsche
junge Kolleginnen dabei haben. Und ehrlich
gesagt, wenn ich auf das Unternehmen
blicke, wie es heute ist, hat sich daran
sehr wenig geändert. Ich denke, wir treten
bei MeToo und Sexismus am Arbeitsplatz
immer noch auf der Stelle, weil viele
Debatten oder viele Klagen von jungen
Frauen verharmlost werden oder bagatellisiert
werden. Da heißt es schnell
‚Das war doch eine einvernehmliche
Beziehung‘, aber dieser Begriff ist eben
grob irreführend, weil er eben
völlig ignoriert, dass eine junge Frau
diesem Machtgefälle ausgesetzt war
und auf gut Deutsch, dass sie mit ihrem Chef
ausgehen musste, um ihren Job nicht
zu verlieren. Und sie hat überhaupt kein
Instrument, sich dagegen zu wehren.
In vielen Betrieben gibt es noch nicht mal
eine Beschwerdestelle und da hat
sich wirklich sehr wenig getan.
Magst du es noch mal konkret erklären,
wie du zu der Erkenntnis kommst, dass sich
da noch nicht so viel
geändert hat an den Strukturen.
Weil es diese Fälle gibt. Es gibt
MeToo Fälle, es gibt sie dort. Da muss
ich nur aktuell in die Presse schauen
und das passiert einfach jeden Tag, dass sich
junge Frauen fragen, in der Medienwelt
oder auch in der freien Wirtschaft,
dass wenn ich jetzt nicht mit meinem
Chef Abendessen gehe, habe ich dann noch morgen
meinen Job. Und das ist wirklich eine existenzielle
Angst. Da geht es um Miete
zahlen, um Kohle und überhaupt um die ganze
berufliche Laufbahn. Das sind gut
ausgebildete Frauen, die kommen
aus dem Studium, die haben Abitur gemacht
und denken so ‚Cool, jetzt werde
ich für mein Knowledge hier eingestellt‘
und am Ende sitzen sie da und denken
‚Jetzt kann ich mir ein kurzes Kleid
anziehen, um mit dem Arsch da essen
zu gehen‘. Entschuldigung.
Und so hast du dich selber gefühlt? -
Auf jeden Fall. - Désirée, wenn Menschen
das Stichwort Hashtag MeToo hören,
dann denken ganz viele direkt an Hollywood,
an die Schauspielbranche. Wie war
das denn für dich als junge Frau, als du
in diese Branche eingestiegen bist?
Hast du da ähnliche Erfahrungen gemacht
wie zum Beispiel Caro? Natürlich
überhaupt nicht. Alles, was eben gesagt wurde über
journalistische Praktiken,
beispielsweise bei diesem Wort jetzt Springer, na dann
gehen Sie mal zum Theater. Am Theater
werden nicht wie beim Journalismus
Ereignisse und Fakten seziert,
sondern Gefühle. Das heißt Theaterstücke,
Emotionen, Liebe, Leid, Lust,
Begehren, Trennung, Verlieben. Ich nenne
das aus diesem Grund, weil das, was als so
unerträglich, dass man mit jemand essen
gehen muss. Ich meine das ist 24
Stunden der Alltag einer Schauspielerin.
Und als Frau und das habe ich gelernt,
habe ich jederzeit die Wahl,
mitzuspielen oder nicht mitzuspielen.
Und daher möchte ich doch auch die Frauen
bitten, sich dem gar nicht erst
zur Verfügung zu stellen. Also es sind
auch gewisse Punkte über die ich gerne
noch mal sprechen würde, denn ich glaube,
wir könnten mit einer korrekten
Attitude die Frauenbewegung sehr beschleunigen.
Jede Frau hat die Möglichkeit zu sagen
‚Ich gehe nicht mit dem Regisseur nachts
halb zwölf in sein Hotelzimmer‘,
sondern ich sage ‚Wir sehen uns morgen am besten
im Büro, wo zwischen uns beiden
ein Schreibtisch steht. Bitte rufen
Sie mein Management an‘. Silvi, kann
jede Frau einfach sagen ‚Nein, ich komme heute
-Abend nicht mit ins Restaurant‘?
-Also ich glaube, da spricht man oder Sie
jetzt einfach sehr aus einer privilegierten
Position, weil ich glaube
nicht, dass jede Frau das machen
kann. Also, wenn ich jetzt in einem Restaurant
bin und um meinen Job fürchten muss,
wenn ich dann nein sage, dann bringe ich mich
ja in eine sehr prekäre Lage, weil mein Job
dann vielleicht draufgeht und ich dann
meine Miete nicht mehr zahlen kann.
Das sind halt Probleme, die um die Existenz
gehen und das ist halt schon sehr privilegiert,
das so zu verallgemeinern.
Ich würde es nicht privilegiert
nennen, ich nenne es selbstbewusst. Niemals wäre
ich auf den Gedanken zu kommen,
mit jemanden sexuell mich einzulassen,
in der Hoffnung auf berufliche
Privilegien oder Vorteile. Wenn jemand mit mir
arbeiten will, dann betrachte ich dieses Verhältnis
rein professionell,
arbeitsbezogen und die Linie, ich meine,
es kann ja sein, dass mir jemand sogar
gefällt. Umso besser, wenn mir der Regisseur
sogar gefällt. Und ich möchte
mit dem auch was zu tun haben,
wenn er beispielsweise mein Gärtner wäre
und ich mir keine Vorteile
beruflich davon verspreche, habe ich doch
auch die Möglichkeit
meinem Herzen zu folgen.
Also das Leben ist ja keine
romantische Komödie und natürlich.
-Ja bei mir schon gar nicht.
-Nein, aber ich meine, nicht jede Frau kann
nein sagen. Nicht jede Frau kann
auch den Mann heiraten, den sie will,
wenn sie irgendwo auf dem Dorf
sitzt. Da sind da fünf Typen und die haben
vielleicht traditionelle Ansichten
und sie will da vielleicht nicht wegziehen,
dann ist das eben ihre Auswahl. Ich meine,
Sie sind berühmt, Sie haben Geld,
Sie können sich aussuchen, was sie wollen
im Leben. Nicht nur Männer, nicht
nur Jobangebote. Das hat nicht jede
Frau. Und natürlich, das ist eine reine Bubbel
Diskussion zu sagen ‚Ich kann mich
in den Regisseur verlieben oder es kann ja
auch romantisch werden‘.
Das ist doch bagatellisiert.
Das habe ich ja nun gerade aus dem Grunde
genannt, weil ich es nicht so strikt
rigide betrachte. Ich trenne es nur in der Sichtweise.
Mein Berufsleben ist nicht
mein Privatleben, ich mache mich nicht
zum Opfer. Ich stehe für alles zur Verfügung,
ohne dass ich etwas von mir hergebe,
was ich nicht wirklich möchte. Ulf, ich komm
gleich zu dir. Ganz kurz. Ich möchte
einen Vorschlag machen, weil ich finde,
was ihr gesagt habt, ist total wichtig
und auch nicht wegzudiskutieren, dass Asset,
wenn auch nur das Gefühl ist
so. Und ich würde es gerne, so richtig
ich die Differenzierungen finde,
rausholen aus der Ebene der persönlichen
Entscheidung. Da sind wir nämlich schon
in einer Situation, die wenig hilfreich ist.
Diese persönlichen Entscheidungen, ob sie privilegiert
oder nicht privilegiert sind,
delegieren die Verantwortung am Ende
auf den Einzelnen und es gibt Machtasymmetrien
vollkommen klar. Die kann man
weder wegdiskutieren, noch macht es Sinn,
sie zu bagatellisieren und so weiter.
Und wenn ich noch mal meinen Case machen
dürfte, warum ich glaube, dass sich in den vergangenen
fünf Jahren was verändert hat,
weil darüber mehr geschrieben,
nachgedacht, rapportiert, recherchiert
und wenn wir Google Search angucken
wollen, würde ich sagen, da ist einiges
passiert. Also ich glaube, MeToo hat
insofern vieles verändert, als auch viele
Tabus und auch Ängste, diese Themen
anzusprechen, sexuellen Missbrauch,
Belästigung erfreulicherweise
weggefallen sind. Ich glaube, das ist ein Anfang.
Es ist aber noch nicht das, wo wir hinkommen
müssen. Insofern bin
ich gespannt, wie das weitergeht.
Jetzt komme ich zu der eigentlichen Veränderung
der Diskussion, die ich anregen
möchte. Wir brauchen einen rechtssicheren Raum,
der diese Dinge so regelt und definiert,
dass sich niemand in der Situation fühlen
muss, ob er jetzt super
unterprivilegiert ist oder super privilegiert, ist egal.
Recht gilt für alle gleichermaßen,
dass allein die Situation so ist, dass man
das gar nicht jetzt zum ‚Ich muss
mich jetzt entscheiden ja oder nein‘,
sondern einfach sagen kann ‚Das ist
nicht akzeptabel‘. So, und dann gibt es zwei
Formen von Recht: Die eine ist die klassische
Rechtsprechung. Ich würde immer
so sagen, da gibt es schon
Hinweise, aber viel wichtiger ist, dass sich
die Unternehmen allesamt, es geht ja
nicht nur, wir sollten ja nicht nur über Medien
reden. Es gibt es ja in jedem anderen
Unternehmen und mittelständischen Betrieb
auch diese Themen. Dass sich
Unternehmen eine Compliance, wie das so schön heißt,
ja, ein Code of Conduct
auferlegen, der absolut unmissverständlich ist.
Ich denke, dass mit diesem Compliance
Rahmen, der jetzt geschaffen wurde,
das hat sozusagen ein juristisches
Regelwerk in manchen Unternehmen, wenn man
es denn anwendet, darüber gelegt. Und das ist
auch gut so. Und das wird dazu führen,
dass es besser wird. Aber was ein großes
Problem, auch dieses Compliance bedeutet
ja, dass Frauen oder auch überhaupt
Betroffene jeden Geschlechts sich
sozusagen beschweren können beim
Betriebsrat, bei der Beschwerdestelle.
Und es wird ein juristisches
Verfahren, ein internes juristisches Verfahren
eingeleitet, ein Untersuchungs-,
Ermittlungsverfahren, was da genau
passiert ist. Das Problem ist nur am Ende:
Was ist die Message oder was ist
die Sichtweise auf die Betroffenen? In den letzten
Monaten ist es so oft passiert,
dass Betroffene, nachdem sie sozusagen
öffentlich gemacht haben, dass es,
dass sie ein MeToo-Fall,
dass sie diffamiert wurden,
dass sie auch von Gerichten
mundtot gemacht wurden. Und die Message
an die jungen Frauen da draußen
ist jetzt im Grunde: Wir hören nicht zu.
Das wäre fatal. Ich will nur, dass es kein
Missverständnis gibt. Das wäre und ist
fatal, wenn es so wäre. Es ist nicht
ganz meine Wahrnehmung. Lasst uns doch sagen...
Aber ich meine, wo hat eine Betroffene
in den letzten 12 Monaten, sagen wir mal,
wirklich bei Weinstein war okay,
in Amerika, wenn auch eine andere Kultur
herrscht. Aber wann hat sich eine Frau
wirklich gut sozusagen aus dieser Lage
in einem geschützten Raum da äußern
können, ohne dass es für sie Nachteile
hatte? Ich meine, ich bin heutzutage
noch als Frau, würde ich immer noch sagen
ich bin doch nicht bescheuert. Ich fange
erst was mit meinem Chef an und oder muss
was mit meinem Chef anfangen, weil ich sonst
in eine dumme Situation komme
für mich. Dann erzähle ich das auch noch
öffentlich und dann bekomme ich nie wieder
einen Job, weil ich dann
daraufhin diffamiert bin. Also ich meine,
welche junge Berufseinsteigerin würde
das heutzutage machen? Es ist immer noch
die Message: Wenn du so was erlebst,
äußere dich besser nicht.
Mich würde mal interessieren, was ihr denkt.
Was hat sich denn für euch
verändert nach fast fünf Jahren
MeToo? Schreibt mir gerne mal eure Erfahrungen
und Gedanken in die Kommentare. Ihr habt
euch alle vom grünen Feld einen kleinen
Minischritt auf Ulf zu bewegt.
Silvi, du hast vorher noch ganz kurz vorher
zu Désirée deine Augen gedreht, sodass
sie dir fast ausgefallen sind. Magst du noch
-mal sagen warum?
-Ja, tut mir leid, da ist mir die Mimik ein
bisschen entgleist, weil ich habe die ganze
Zeit nur ich, ich, ich, ich gehört.
Und bei der MeToo-Bewegung
geht es ja eben nicht nur um ich, ich,
ich und meine individuellen
Erfahrungen, sondern einfach Empathie zu entwickeln
für Erfahrungen von ganz vielen
Frauen, die ja auch ihre Erlebnisse geteilt haben
und auch Männer, die es geteilt
haben, aber vorwiegend natürlich Frauen,
die es geteilt haben. Und dass man
dem Ganzen Anerkennung schenkt und nicht
die ganze Zeit das Ganze wieder so
dreht, dass es auf sich die ganze Zeit bezogen
ist, das ist total wichtig. Ich finde,
das Problematischste an der MeToo-Bewegung ist
einfach diese gnadenlose und brutale
Wahrheit, die einem da entgegen
geschmettert wird, dass Frauen, die sich
in der Öffentlichkeit dazu äußern,
einfach immer mit Victim Blaming
im Anschluss zu tun haben. Das heißt,
sie werden eigentlich immer als Lügnerin
bezeichnet oder ihnen wird nicht geglaubt.
Und das sehe ich als problematisch an.
Ich persönlich habe auch Erfahrungen gemacht,
wo ich mich selber behaupten musste
gegen Männer, die übergriffig sich mir gegenüber
verhalten haben und mir unmoralische
Angebote gemacht haben. Und ich habe nein
gesagt und ich war sauer, ich war
wütend und ich habe mich behauptet und war
selbstbewusst. Und trotzdem, als ich das dann
in der Öffentlichkeit gesagt habe,
ohne die Namen zu nennen, habe ich einen
Shitstorm erlebt vom Allerfeinsten.
Ich wurde als Lügnerin betitelt, man
hat mir nicht geglaubt, ich habe nicht mal
die Namen genannt und trotzdem ist
die ganze Verantwortung auf mich abgewälzt
worden. Und das ist das, was immer
passiert und auch, was gerade passiert
ist. Wenn wir darüber reden, dass die MeToo-Bewegung
einfach sensibilisieren
soll, wird der Fokus immer auf die Frauen
gelegt. Warum sie das denn jetzt machen,
warum sie sich jetzt in die Opferposition
begeben, warum sie das erzählen?
Warum hört man nicht einfach erst mal
zu und erkennt erst mal an, dass was passiert
ist? Und wenn man bedenkt, dass nur 5
Prozent sich überhaupt trauen, zur Polizei
zu gehen und das Ganze überhaupt zu melden
und 95 Prozent sich das nicht mal trauen,
muss man sich die Frage stellen:
Warum trauen sich diese 95 Prozent das nicht?
Das ist doch der Kern. Warum haben wir eine Gesellschaft
in in der eine Frau sich
nicht traut, öffentlich
darüber zu sprechen, weil die Fälle,
die an die Öffentlichkeit kommen, das ist
ja ein Bruchteil von dem, was passiert,
wirklich. Und das macht mich einfach
wütend, dass man das dann einfach auf sich
bezieht, weil es geht darum glaube ich,
Empathie zu entwickeln in diesen Momenten.
-Ja - Ich möchte dazu sagen, ich habe
von mir gesprochen, weil ihr mich
als privilegiert bezeichnet, was ich,
womit ich mich überhaupt nicht
identifizieren kann. Dass man
natürlich den Blick auf die Mehrzahl der Frauen
lenkt, das ist doch eine Selbstverständlichkeit.
Und deshalb sage
ich ja auch Gott sei Dank, dass es Hashtag
MeToo gibt, dass diese Debatte überhaupt
mal zur Sprache gekommen wird, denn
alles, was in der Frauenbewegung Frauen sich
an Terrain erkämpft haben, ist ein Feld,
was ihnen nicht freiwillig von Männern
zugestanden worden ist, sondern es ist
ein Feld, was sie der Macht der Männer
abringen mussten. Sie mussten mit durch
geschichtliche und durch viele Beweise
sich erkämpfen, erstreiten und den Männern
abringen, was eigentlich
ihre Gleichberechtigung ist. Und das zieht
sich durch alle Bereiche und das finde
ich eigentlich beschämend, dass vom Geschenk
Gottes, dem man als solchen
den Frauen die Ebenbürtigkeit
nicht freiwillig zugestanden wurde,
sondern einen Kampf erforderlich
gemacht hat. Anil, ich würde gerne noch mal dich
ansprechen. Du engagiert sich bei der HeForShe-Bewegung
und setzt dich dort
für Gleichberechtigung ein, auch zum Thema
toxische Männlichkeit. Du sagst
ein Problem beim aktuellen
gesellschaftlichen Stand zum Thema MeToo
ist, dass wir nach fast fünf Jahren
eigentlich immer noch keine Ahnung haben,
wo Machtmissbrauch, sexuelle
Belästigung oder Gewalt auch überhaupt anfängt.
An welchen Erkenntnissen machst du
das überhaupt, würdest du das festmachen,
-quasi?
-Ich glaube erst mal natürlich auch
persönlich, weil ich ja selber in so
einem Prozess bin und ich mich selber
auch von dieser toxischen
Männlichkeit, das überhaupt erst mal anerkennen muss,
dass es das gibt und dass ist ein Teil
einer Männlichkeitskonstruktion ist,
die in unserer Gesellschaft
vorherrschend ist. Und gleichzeitig sieht man
das zum Beispiel, wenn es Fälle gibt,
wo Grenzüberschreitungen öffentlich gemacht
worden sind, dass die Reaktionen darauf
im Prinzip klassisch, toxische Männlichkeit
ist. Männer müssen sich endlich nicht
nur als Teil des Problems, was sie sind,
sehen, sondern als Teil der Lösung.
Sie müssen anfangen umzudenken. Sie müssen
Sexismus verlernen und sie müssen
vor allem anfangen zuzuhören, denn alle
diese Dinge stehen schon länger
auf dem Tisch. Aber Männer sind jetzt
in der Pflicht, ihr Verhalten
radikal zu verändern und um endlich MeToo
auch ein Stück weit nach vorne zu bringen.
Wenn es in dem Maße so viele verschiedene
Fälle gab, wo ein Herr Reichelt
mit Praktikantinnen, mit Auszubildenden
irgendwas hatte und er dann immer sagt,
es ist Quatsch und die Vorwürfe sind Quatsch,
dann sagt das auch irgendwas
über die Tat, über die Art und Weise,
mit welchen Privilegien Männer immer
noch durch die Gegend laufen und sagen können
‚Es war nichts und ich bin
eigentlich das große Opfer‘.
Ulf, was macht denn der Fall Reichelt
für dich deutlich? Also einfach Verantwortung
übernehmen, Kultur verändern und wenn du
mich fragst, würde ich sagen: Es ist
meine Verantwortung dafür zu sorgen,
dass das, was du gesagt hast, sich so nicht
-fortsetzen kann.
-Sie sagen, es ist viel getan worden. Was
-genau?
-Also, ich kann ja nur ganz konkret für
meinen Verantwortungsbereich sprechen.
Und wenn du mich fragst, dann sage ich dir
ganz klar, es gibt einfach keine
Toleranz für sowas und das muss gelebt werden,
es muss von der Führung vorgelebt
werden und man ist ja nicht als Angestellter,
in welchem Angestelltenverhältnis
auch immer, in einem rechtsfreien Raum.
Wir haben einen sehr starken und auch wie ich finde,
sehr engagierten Betriebsrat.
Wir haben diese Themen sehr offen
angesprochen, schon vor dem gerade
geschilderten Fall, der jetzt
sehr viel Wellen geschlagen hat.
Und die Sensibilität ist
auch schon sehr viel länger da.
Ich kann das vielleicht aus der persönlichen
Perspektive, kann
ich das natürlich nicht
nachvollziehen Herr Poschardt, aber die ‚Die Welt‘
und die Zeitung ist jetzt auch nicht
dafür bekannt, antisexistische
und und feministische
Artikel zu schreiben, die diese ganzen
-Errungenschaften immer wieder...
-Das ist einfach falsch. Also da kann ich
nur empfehlen, lesen Sie Rebecca
Schönbach bei uns, lesen Sie unsere saudiarabische
Kolumnistin oder die Kollegin, die aus Saudi-Arabien
nach Deutschland geflohen
ist, die das Frauenthema anspricht,
also diese Themen werden, Mara Delius,
Hannah Lühmann. Also wir haben so
viele Autorinnen und Autoren, die dieses Thema
ansprechen. Ich glaube, da leben
Sie in sehr einfachen Fachbildern.
Sie haben jetzt zwei Autorinnen
genannt, Entschuldigung, dass ich Sie unterbreche,
die gegen gendergerechte
Sprache angeschrieben haben.
Aber gendergerechte Sprache und Machtmissbrauch
sind zwei verschiedene
-Debatten.
-Wir reden ja über feministische Artikel.
-Also...
-Wissen wir ja von Alice Schwarzer. Es gibt
auch feministische Positionen ohne Gendersprache
und ich glaube, das müssen
wir einfach trennen, wenn wir sagen,
wir wollen Machtmissbrauch,
sexuelle Übergriffe, all das ist
ein wichtiges Thema, wenn man das in einen
Topf schmeißt mit irgendwelchen
sprachlichen, ideologischen Operationen,
dann wird es schon ein bisschen
schwierig. Anil, die Frage an dich: Caro hat
es gerade schon angesprochen, in den USA
beobachten wir auf jeden Fall,
dass es dort, das MeToo zu einem ganz
anderen Verhalten auch in den Unternehmen
geführt hat. Manchmal hat man fast das Gefühl,
dass aus Angst sehr viel schneller
reagiert wird als hier und es gibt
dort auf jeden Fall schneller Konsequenzen
als hier. Also sieht man zum Beispiel
auch daran, dass der Marktwert von Unternehmen
ziemlich schnell sinkt, alleine nur durch
den MeToo-Vorwurf. Warum funktioniert
-das in den USA so viel besser als bei uns?
-Das glaube ich, kann ich in der Form gar
nicht beantworten. Ich glaube schon,
dass es, wir dürfen auch nicht vergessen,
wir reden immer von MeToo, aber
die Art und Weise und die Themen, über
die im Rahmen von MeToo gesprochen
werden, die gibt es ja schon seit 2013. Es gab
da auch Aufschrei damals und so. Und ich finde,
die Frage ist insofern interessant.
Ich habe auch immer das Gefühl, dass Deutschland
ist dann immer so ein bisschen
weiterdenkt, als sie dann eigentlich
sind. Und in internationalen Vergleich belegt
Deutschland den hinteren
Mittelfeldplatz. Also von, Sie sagten ja schon
Rechtsprechung, ich bin da voll
bei Ihnen ist es total wichtig, aber
wenn es zum Beispiel darum geht,
wie Werbung in den Medien platziert wird.
Es gibt in Spanien, in Norwegen gibt
es eine Regelung, wo sexistische Werbung
verboten wird. Ich glaube, die Frage
ist, warum das hier in Deutschland nicht
passiert, weil es ist wichtig, dass wir über
Rechtsprechung reden, es ist wichtig,
dass wir über Compliance etc.
reden, aber das ist doch, das kann doch nicht
der Endpunkt sein, von dem wo wir uns
begegnen. Wir müssen uns doch die Frage
stellen: Ein Rainer Brüderle 2013,
hat offensichtlich Scheiße gebaut. Was ist
mit dem passiert hat? Hat der irgendwie
seinen Job verloren hat, der ist immer
noch in irgendwelchen Positionen so.
Ein Julian Reichelt durfte jetzt bei ServusTV
wieder irgendwelche Sachen schwätzen.
Ein Luke Mockridge hat danach direkt von Sat1
zum Beipiel Schutz bekommen. Und wem
wurde direkt danach noch eine Show angeboten?
-Jetzt ist er wieder auf Tour, ja.
-Zum Beispiel so, Samara hat danach direkt
ein Nummer eins Album gehabt,
so. Das darf man doch nicht vergessen.
Ich würde gerne mal wissen wollen,
wo das dann aufhört, wenn man sagt ‚Ja,
wir wollen auch Werbung verändern‘,
also welche Welt steht da am Ende? Ich bin
wirklich neugierig. Welche Welt
ist am Ende die Welt, die sozusagen
eine progressive, nicht MeToo Welt ist?
Würde mich wirklich, eine Frage, ist keine
Aussage. Interessant, dass Leute
bei einer Frage zurückgehen.
Also diese Äußerung, das Narrativ, das wo wir dann
am Ende damit enden. Ich glaube,
wir werden am Ende in einer ganz
anderen Welt leben wollen. Das ist glaube
ich klar, da bin ich mir sicher
und das ist auch okay für mich. Wir alle
gemeinsam. Ich glaube, Sie haben
eine andere Vorstellung von dem,
wo wir vielleicht auch landen, mit welchen Schritten
wir da landen. Ich glaube,
wir sind uns schon darüber einig,
dass es ein Problem gibt und das will
ich auf jeden Fall anerkennen. Das ist
ja keine Frage, auf die es eine Ja oder Nein
Antwortmöglichkeit gibt, sondern das ist:
Wo kommen wir denn da hin,
wenn wir als Werbung
auch noch bestimmen wollen-
So habe ich das nicht gesagt. Ich habe
wirklich gefragt. Die Frage ist,
-wie definieren wir, wo fängt Sexismus an?
-Wollen wir das auch noch verändern? Wollen
wir das jetzt auch noch?
Das war die Frage.
Die Frage ist, wenn man
kulturhistorisch auf die Rolle von Erotik
bei der Darstellung des Menschen kann
man von der Höhlenmalerei bis heute so ziehen.
Wo fangen wir an zu sagen:
Da wird es sexistisch. Dann können
wir unsere Kulturgeschichte
dekonstruieren. Es gibt ja
auch Intellektuelle, die das als interessantes
Projekt haben. Ich glaube
-nur, das sind zwei verschiedene Themen.
-Ich glaube, was sie sagen möchte: Das
Klima muss sich ändern. Da hat er auch recht,
dass man- Es geht um Paragraf 219,
es geht auch um die körperliche
Selbstbestimmung von Frauen.
Aber lass uns bitte
konkret beim Thema MeToo bleiben-
Damit MeToo nicht mehr passiert,
muss das ganze gesellschaftliche Biotop sich
-ändern, die ganze Stimmung.
-Deswegen würde ich gerne noch mal kurz zu
dem inhaltlichen Punkt von dir
zurückkommen, Anil. Du hast gesagt,
die Konsequenzen sind oft, also gerade
bei deutschen MeToo-Debatten, zu schwach.
Was sagt ihr denn als gelbes Feld dazu?
Ralf, was sagst du? Nein, die Konsequenzen
sind ja in Deutschland, ähnlich wie in Amerika
eigentlich immer ein bisschen
zu drastisch und überzogen. Man
hat doch in der ein oder anderen Stelle,
als der Zug erst mal am Rollen war,
übertrieben. Und es gab auch eine ganze
Reihe von Selbstmorden von Männern, die öffentlich
an den Pranger gestellt wurden,
bevor überhaupt geklärt war, was genau
passiert ist. Einige, die ihre Posten
verloren haben, haben das vollkommen
zu Recht getan. Es gab aber auch wirklich
echte Opfer, die nicht hätten sein müssen.
Ich möchte noch mal zurückkommen zu Rainer
Brüderle und Laura Himmelreich. Die erste
Beleidigung ging von Frau Himmelreich aus,
sie hat ihn nämlich wegen seines
Alters beleidigt, woraufhin er einen Altherren
Move machte. Sehr unreflektiert, aber
das würde ich ihm auch gar nicht so wahnsinnig
vorwerfen wollen. Und mit einem
Kompliment antwortete, das nicht mehr als Kompliment
gelten kann, weil er auf die Oberweite
anspielte. Und das Ganze ist dann
vollkommen verunglückt, weil Himmelreich
machte dann Karriere und Brüderle war
erledigt. Von Anfang an war die Macht
bei der Journalistin, nicht bei Herrn
Brüderle. Er war erledigt,
also das, was du gesagt hast-
Das stimmt auch nicht. Der war nicht
erledigt, der war vielleicht vorher schon
-erledigt, aber der war nicht so,
--die erste Beleidigung von ihr auf sein
Alter und dass er nicht mehr
politisch potent ist auch gemeint. Das muss man
genau nachlesen. Würdest du Ralf dabei
zustimmen, dass die Konsequenzen teilweise
zu hart sind in Deutschland, oder auch gleich
hart sind wie in den USA?
Nein, auf gar keinen Fall. Also in den USA
kam Weinstein ja jetzt für über 20 Jahre
ins Gefängnis. Ich glaube nicht, dass das in Deutschland
schon passiert ist. Jemals.
Es gibt hier die großen Fälle Jörg
Kachelmann, Horst Arnold und so weiter
-mit Falschbeschuldigung-
-Jörg Kachelmann möchte nicht mehr genannt
werden in solchen Fällen. Das hat er selber
auf Twitter gesagt, 2017. Er möchte
da bei solchen Debatten nicht mehr als Beispiel
herangezogen werden. Das sollten
wir auch berücksichtigen, weil es dieses cherry
picking, was ja gerade passiert,
also dieses: Es gibt Frauen, die das auch machen
und die gibt es auch. Ja,
natürlich gibt es das. Aber wenn man
sich die Statistiken einfach mal anguckt,
sieht man halt einfach, dass die Mehrheit
und zwar die massive Mehrheit anders rum
passiert und dass da ja können sie jetzt
den Kopf schütteln. Aber das ist halt
die Lebensrealität von Frauen und das können
sie vielleicht jetzt nicht so
nachvollziehen, aber deswegen habe ich ja
die Empathie auch vorhin angesprochen.
Deswegen noch mal konkret zu deinem
Fall. Du bist YouTuberin und du hast vor einigen
Jahren ein Video veröffentlicht, in dem du
von persönlichen Erfahrungen mit sexueller
Belästigung von zwei anderen großen
erfolgreichen YouTubern berichtet hast.
Wie war das denn für dich? Was für Reaktionen
hast du zum Beispiel bekommen?
Und wie geht es dir jetzt einige
Jahre später, damit mit den öffentlichen
-Reaktionen?
-Also ich hatte den Shitstorm zweimal,
einmal, als ich die Namen nicht
genannt habe, vier Jahre später, als ein früherer
befreundeter Kollege einfach
die Namen ungefragt gedropt hat
in der Öffentlichkeit. Und dann ging
also die ganze Sache noch mal richtig hoch.
Und das war intensiv, weil ich habe
Drohnachrichten bekommen. Ich habe
das selber ja auch gar nicht
entschieden. Es waren eigentlich durchgängig immer
nur Übergriffigkeiten von Männern mir
gegenüber, obwohl ich mich nie als Opfer
gefühlt habe, sondern eigentlich
stark sein wollte und dagegen vorgehen wollte.
Ich wollte sensibilisieren und aufklären
und was ich dafür bekommen habe, war
am Ende des Tages
Hass. Und zwar ziemlich viel.
Anil, glaubst du, dass das, was Silvi
gerade erzählt hat, der Grund ist,
warum vielen Frauen das überhaupt so
schwer fällt, das öffentlich zu machen?
-Also genau diese Reaktion.
-Absolut, weil wir hatten es ja eben auch
schon angesprochen, diese Männer
nehmen sich ja dann auch in der Form
diese Sicherheit, weil sie wissen,
es gibt erstens eine Rechtsprechung
und ein Rechtssystem, das sie in der Regel
wie auch die Zahlen, die Silvi nannte,
sie schützt. Sie wissen, dass sie schützt.
Die schützen sich gegenseitig. Wir hatten
das auch bei diversen anderen Fällen,
wo dann andere Promis auch angefangen haben
und auf Instagram zum Beispiel zu schreiben:
Ich bin hinter dir, jo Bro,
ich bin auf jeden Fall hinter
dir. Wissend, dass diese Befürchtung da-
Und Stichwort digitale
Welt, so die Gleichstellungspolitik
der Bundesregierung, übrigens
sehr interessant, sagt ja auch, wer
zum Beispiel in den sozialen Medien
vor allem repräsentiert, dass das sind
meistens weiße cis heterosexuelle
Männer, die repräsentiert sind. Und es gibt aber
auch Zahlen, wonach eben viele Frauen
vor allem diskriminiert werden. Und es gibt
eine sehr klare Vorstellung, zum Beispiel
Stichwort Rollenbilder, wie Männer
zu sein haben, wie Frauen zu sein haben
und wie binär diese ganze Gleichstellung
heißt. Wir müssen uns schon die Frage
stellen: Es gibt, es gibt Ängste
und ich bin auch voll bei dir,
wir brauchen angstfreien Raum. Das ist
das Wichtigste. Aber diese angstfreier
Raum, der muss erst mal nicht
nur von den Leuten gedacht und strukturiert
werden, die eigentlich
für diese Ängste zuständig sind. Und deshalb,
denke ich, ist es ein wichtiger
Schritt, da anzufangen, weil Männlichkeit
mit das größte Problem dieser ganzen
-Debatte ist.
-Aber ich habe mir nur überlegt, wie es
wohl sein kann unter Betrachtung all
dieser Argumente, dass am Beginn des 21.
Jahrhunderts Frauen in diese Formate
gehen, wie Der Bachelor,
stark sexualisiert, wie in einem Harem
sich einem Manne anbieten, um als größten
Traum zu erleben, wie sie aus der Masse
herausgepickt werden
mit der Entscheidungsmacht eines
einzelnen Mannes. Wie lässt sich denn das dann
einordnen? Ist ja auch eine Spiegelung
unseres Zeitgeistes.
-Ich verstehe jetzt gerade die Frage nicht.
-Wie ist das vereinbar, dass Frauen das
andererseits tun, während wir doch
dankbar sind um die MeToo-Debatte?
Ja, aber das ist doch einfach nur eine Sendung,
die die traditionelle Sicht
bestätigt. Und darauf hin-
Deswegen ist es ja für Frauen so toxisch,
Natürlich ist das, was Désirée gesagt
hat mit diesen Formaten. Ich weiß nicht, Sat1,
RTL2, wo auch immer das läuft, das markierten,
fast archaisches Verständnis
dieser Rollen Unterschiede. Und wenn wir sagen,
wenn wir nach Gemeinsamkeiten
suchen, dann müssen wir doch
sagen: Wollen wir eine Gesellschaft haben,
eine Liberale, in der das eine Option
ist. Und wir lassen es zu, weil es eben Frauen
und Männer gibt, die das irgendwie
okay finden. Und wir wollen aber gleichzeitig
eine andere Gesellschaft haben.
Wie moderieren wir so einen Prozess,
ohne Dinge zu verbieten? Wie gestalten
wir einen kulturellen Wandel, ohne andere
Positionen abzuwerten? Ich habe
mehr Fragen als Lösungen.
Wenn eine Gruppe von Männern oder von privilegierten
Männern oder Männern,
die in der Position sind, eben
Frauen das Leben schwer zu machen, eben
und auch diese MeToo Fälle zu produzieren
bereit wäre, ein Schritt beiseite
zu treten und ihr von ihrer
Position zurückzuziehen und zu sagen: Okay,
wir machen jetzt Platz und wir wollen
wirklich etwas ändern. Absurd. Aber dann
stellt sich diese Frage gar nicht
mehr, wo wir liberale Rechte beschneiden,
weil das würde sich dann,
das würde sich dann aus Höflichkeit
und aus Menschenfreundlichkeit
einfach fügen. Weil wenn sich diese, nennen
wir es toxische Männlichkeit
bewegen würde, würden sich viele dieser Fragen
von alleine gar nicht mehr
stellen. Dann würden wir nämlich sagen O.k.
Gendergerechte Sprache, weil wir wollen
freundlich und respektvoll mit all unseren
Mitmenschen sein. Mehr
feministische Positionen, weil wir wollen breiter
diskutieren, weniger sexistische
Werbung, weil wir wollen niemandes Gefühle
verletzen, schon gar nicht die von Frauen.
Das hat dann nichts mehr mit liberalen
Grundprinzipien zu tun, sondern einfach
Wie weit verletzen wir unsere Mitmenschen
oder nicht? Oder wie weit waren wir auch deren Rechte
und und und deren Integrität.
Also die Gesellschaft organisiert
sich selber dorthin, weil bei Werbung-
-wenn wir das Problem dieser toxischen
Männlichkeit angehen, dann würden sich
eben viele Dinge neu gruppieren und fügen.
Ich muss jetzt mal was zur toxischen
Männlichkeit sagen. Männlichkeit
kann eigentlich nicht toxisch sein.
Dieser Begriff hat sich ja jetzt
geprägt. Der wird benutzt, funktioniert
auch einigermaßen. Dennoch, wenn wir jetzt
so häufig das fallen lassen, zusammen
mit Menschenfreundlichkeit. Es gibt
einen Fachbegriff in der Psychoanalyse,
das heißt Überännlichkeit,
Hypermaskulinität und das ist etwas,
was in der kulturellen Genetik
bei uns sehr, sehr tief verankert ist.
In der Regel ist es ganz banal und nicht
so theoretisch, wie es jetzt angefangen
habe. Der kleine Junge ist zu Hause, er ist
nur unter Frauen. Die Männer sind weg.
Der Vater fährt einen großen LKW auf einer großen
Autobahn. Er führt ein großes
Medienhaus oder er bedient eine gefährliche
Kreissäge. Irgendetwas,
was für den kleinen Jungen in dem Moment,
wo er merkt, dass er nicht ein Mädchen
ist, wie die meisten um ihn
herum, die Mütter, die Tanten,
die Kindergärtnerinnen, die Grundschullehrerinnen
und mittlerweile
auch die Mittelstufelehrerin.
Und er stellt sich Männlichkeit
als etwas Gigantisches vor und kriegt
Schiss. Er glaubt, das kann er nicht
erreichen. Und genau dieser Zusammenhang
führt dazu, dass hinterher ein Verhalten
auftritt, das wir toxisch nennen und auch tatsächlich
toxisch ist, vor allem
-auch für diese Jungs oder jungen Männer.
-Glaubst du denn, dass dann vielleicht
genau mit dem, was du gerade
ansprichst, MeToo auch eine Chance für Männer
sein kann, sich selbst zu sensibilisieren
und so das eigene Verhalten
zu reflektieren? Absolut. Da kann
ich den Kreis schließen zu Übergriffe
gegen Männer. Die Geschlechtsgrenze
ist metoo gefallen. Das war vorher nicht
der Fall, dass auch Männer über
Übergriffe reden konnten, also von Männern auf Männer
sowieso oder auf Jungs, aber auch von Frauen
auf Männern gibt es einige
sehr gute Beispiele und das begrüße
ich sehr. Deswegen bin ich für den ganzen
Feminismus dankbar. Bin auch für diese MeToo-Bewegung
sehr, sehr dankbar,
weil in der Körperpolitik für Männer
noch sehr viel zu gewinnen ist. Sylvie
Was müsste denn für dich passieren,
dass wir, wenn wir zum Beispiel in fünf Jahren
eine weitere 13 Fragen Folge zu dem Thema
machen, du sagen würdest: Ich stehe
auch auf dem gelben Feld im Sinne
von: Ich unterstütze die These zu sagen 'Ja,
wir haben eigentlich jetzt
schon ziemlich viel erreicht.'?
So traurig das jetzt aus meinem
Mund klingt, finde ich das relativ
unrealistisch, dass das innerhalb von fünf
Jahren passiert. Weil es braucht ja noch
ein bisschen, bis die nächsten
Generation erwachsen werden und was verändern können.
Und natürlich können wir verschiedene
Werkzeuge nutzen, wie zum Beispiel MeToo.
Ich sehe diese Bewegung tatsächlich
als ein Werkzeug, um zu sensibilisieren.
Also dass wir einfach darauf
aufmerksam gemacht werden, dass es diese Fälle gibt
und dass wir miteinander reden
und empathisch aufeinander reagieren.
Das heißt, ich habe nicht nur mit Freundinnen
dank der MeToo-Bewegung über
all das, was das umfasst, geredet,
sondern auch mit männlichen Freunden. Die sind
dann auf einmal offen für diese Themen
waren und auf mich zugegangen sind.
Und ich glaube, wenn man miteinander
redet, dann versteht man auch die andere
Seite besser und kann besser
Empathie entwickeln. Und dadurch können Männer
auch ganz leicht erkennen. Ist das jetzt
eine Übergriffigkeit, weil mein Gegenüber
so und so reagiert? Weil man sieht
das ja eigentlich. Also ich muss dafür ja
eigentlich nichts sprechen. Man merkt
das ja eigentlich, wenn Empathie entwickelt
-wird.
-Désirée, was würdest du denn sagen: Was
müsste eine Frauenbewegung in Zukunft,
also wenn wir jetzt noch mal
in die Zukunft gucken, zum Abschluss
dieser Diskussion anders oder besser
machen als zum Beispiel MeToo?
Also wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel eine neue
Frauenbewegung denkt oder anders
machen als bisher, um Machtmissbrauch besser
bekämpfen zu können. Ohne MeToo würden
wir hier gar nicht stehen. Und diese Debatte,
diese Dinge überhaupt erst mal zu benennen
und mit allen Aspekten zu beleuchten,
ist ja schon ein erster, sehr guter
Anfang. Womit Frauen auf dem Weg zu ihrer
Unabhängigkeit aber nicht gerechnet
haben. Das ist die Tatsache, dass das alte
Programm erhalten geblieben ist. Denn
wann immer auch was schief geht, sie soll dann
doch die tolle Gastgeberin sein. Sie darf
zu Hause keine Fresse ziehen, sie darf
keine schlechte Laune haben. Am besten
auch ordentlich kondoliert, gepflegt sein,
attraktiv bleiben, aber doch dann
auch immer wieder sanft und weiblich.
Und da finde ich, ist das wichtigste
gesellschaftlicher Respekt gerade
von Männern für die Leistung von Frauen
und auf diesem Weg zur Unabhängigkeit alle
mögliche Unterstützung, die es nur gibt.
Denn es ist keineswegs so, dass uns
die Unabhängigkeit von Ballast
befreit hätte. Stimmt ihr dazu? Jetzt versuche
ich noch mal, weil ich so
daran interessiert wäre, so einen Punkt
zu machen. Ich glaube, die Fluchtlinien
heißt noch nicht, dass wir uns
auseinanderdividieren, sondern so
einen kommen Gole haben zu sehen, wie sieht
eine veränderte Männlichkeit aus? Was hat
sich denn schon verändert? Und was du
gesagt hast mit der Angst und auch was dir
widerfahren ist, das darf nicht sein,
das muss das Ziel sein. Und da ist
es gerade schon angesprochen: Ein common
Gole. Deswegen würde ich jetzt gerne
zu den Kompromissen kommen. Ich werde euch
jetzt einen Kompromissvorschlag nennen
und wenn ihr möchtet, könnt ihr gerne einen
Schritt auf mich zugehen und dem zustimmen.
Wenn nicht, bleibt ihr dann
natürlich stehen. Wenn ihr ihn ganz
schrecklich findet, geht ihr einen Schritt
zurück und danach habt ihr noch mal
die Möglichkeit jeweils auf eurem Feld euch
einen Kompromissvorschlag für die andere
Seite zu überlegen, die ihr dann
der anderen Seite vorschlagt und dann
mal schauen, ob ihr noch einen weiteren
Schritt aufeinander zugeht oder nicht.
Elfte Frage von 13 Fragen: Können wir uns
darauf einigen, dass im fünften
Jahr MeToo zwar nicht alles beim Alten ist,
also beispielsweise viele schon
viel sensibilisierter sind, wie wir gerade
besprochen haben, aber deutsche
Unternehmen Machtmissbrauch aktuell immer
noch viel zu wenig offenlegen und ahnden.
Wir sind hier also noch relativ am Anfang.
Wenn ihr mir da zustimmt, könnt
einen Schritt auf mich zugehen. Am Anfang ja.
Wir sind am Anfang. Dann kannst du
einen Schritt auf mich zugehen, wenn du
möchtest. Ihr seid ja auch schon auf mich
zugegangen. Ulf nicht. Ich bin ja fast
schon da. Ich bin ja immer nach vorne-
Du bleibst bleib stehen, aber stimmst zu. Ja,
ich habe dazu ja wirklich hinreichend
viel gesagt. Dann möchte ich euch jetzt gerne
dazu einladen, jeweils auf eurem Feld
euch einen Kompromissvorschlag zu überlegen.
Die Rede mich um Kopf und Kragen,
aber ich habe das Gefühl-
Ich glaube, das wird alles
missverstanden. Ich sehe es also- Okay, das war jetzt
auf jeden Fall schon bis hierhin
eine ziemlich hitzige Diskussion. Ich bin
gespannt, was jetzt hier gleich noch
für Kompromissvorschläge kommen. Und falls
ihr jetzt gerade zuguckt und euch
denkt: 'ich habe noch den ultimativen
Kompromissvorschlag, der jetzt
eigentlich kommen müsste', dann schreibt den gerne
in die Kommentare. Was ist euer Kompromissvorschlag
an das grüne Feld?
Schwache Männer brauchen starke
Frauen. Das ist der Kompromiss? Ja. Okay,
könnt ihr das vielleicht ein bisschen
ausformulieren, was ihr damit meinen?
Welche Männer haben es nötig, auf diese Weise
sich die Liebe oder die Erotik
einer Frau zu erschleichen oder zu erhandeln,
zu erdealen, Angebote
dieser Art zu machen? Es macht doch
die Männer sehr klein, wenn sie es für nötig
halten, auf diese Weise die Liebe
oder die Begierde einer Frau sich zu sichern.
Also es wäre im Grunde genommen
das Gedankenexperiment darin, vor allem
eine defizitäre Form von Männlichkeit
zu sehen, die das braucht. Und die Idee wäre,
wenn man kulturelle Role
Models weiter verändern will, zu sagen,
wenn es eine defizitäre ist, ein anderer
Ausdruck als toxisch. Aber da fehlt
was oder da ist etwas missing, dann
wäre es interessant, wie wir dahin kämen.
Weil und das ist jetzt das Wort
von Désirée, nicht von mir, ich will
es nur versuchen, so zu artikulieren,
dass es eigentlich, englisch gesprochen,
ein enabling von Männlichkeit gibt,
die hinkommt zu einer Souveränität, die so
was vom Selbstbild ausschließt. Und dieser Blick,
den wir jetzt gerade formuliert
haben, der ist post patriarchal. Also
das, was ich von der anderen Seite gehört habe,
war mir immer so ein bisschen, vor allem
bei Anil, ein bisschen zu sehr Schuldlust
auf der männlichen Seite, Angstlust
auf der weiblichen Seite und das halte
ich für eine Neuauflage des
patriarchalen Blicks. Wir brauchen genau das, was jetzt
meine Partner hier gesagt haben meine Partnerinnen,
mein Partner, diesen Blick
darauf, welche Schwäche in diesen vermeintlichen
und echten
Machtmissbräuchen auch liegt. Okay,
dann könnt ihr euch jetzt entscheiden,
ob ihr einen Schritt auf die gelbe
Seite zugehen möchte oder bestehen bleiben
wollt, ob wir einen Schritt zurück
gehen möchte. Ein Mini-Schritt. Warum?
-Warum fällt es dir so schwer gerade?
-Ich glaube es liegt vielleicht an gewissen
Formulierungen. Ich glaube was im Kern,
wo ich glaube ich eine Einigung finde,
weil ich ja auch viel über
Männlichkeit rede- Es braucht auf jeden Fall
eine intensivere, eine radikalere
Diskussion und auch Veränderung
von Männlichkeit, wie sie gerade ist.
Wir sind uns darüber einig, dass jetzt gerade
wie Männlichkeit ist, auf jeden Fall
zum Problem beiträgt. Und wenn ich das so
verstehe, dann sage ich auf jeden Fall
Ja, wir müssen mehr über Männlichkeit reden.
Und ja, Männlichkeit muss sich
verändern. Im Idealfall abschaffen
oder als Herrschaftskategorie
gar überflüssig werden.
Okay, dann könnt ihr gerne
jetzt euren Kompromissvorschlag nennen.
Unser Kompromißvorschlag lautet:
Wir leben in einer frauenfeindlichen,
misogynen Gesellschaft, in der zum Beispiel
der Care-Arbeit immer noch nicht
groß thematisiert wird oder fast
totgeschwiegen wird, in der es Frauen
gewisse Grundrechte vorenthalten
bleiben. Und was jetzt passieren müsste, ist,
dass Frauen diesen Kampf, also diese auch diese,
die den Kampf durch die politischen
Institutionen nicht alleine gehen
müssen, sondern dass viel, viel mehr Initiative
von den Männern kommen muss, um diese Gesellschaft
zu verändern und eben dafür
zu sorgen, dass es eben
diese MeToo Fälle nicht mehr gibt.
Ihr könnt euch jetzt gerne dazu
positionieren. Geht ihr einen Schritt
auf die grüne Seite zu? Ja,
ich finde, ich würde es gerne machen,
wenn ich den letzten Teil für sich
nehme, dann bin ich sofort dabei. Ich finde,
die Bestandsaufnahme ist schon sehr holzschnittartig
und ich finde, wir müssen
aufpassen, dass wir nicht an Pauschalisierungen
ersticken. Es gibt
auch nicht die Männlichkeit, es gibt
auch nicht die misogyne Gesellschaft,
die frauenfeindlichen Umfelder,
sondern es gibt ja selbst in einem Unternehmen,
es gibt selbst in einem
kulturellen Kontext, gibt es immer die und die.
Und wenn man alles in Bausch und Bogen,
so mit so einer düsteren Gegenwartsanalyse,
kann ich nichts anfangen. Also wenn da so
ein bisschen mehr Zuversicht und Aufbruch
drin wäre, dann bin ich da sofort
dabei, weil in der Tat, was nicht passieren darf,
dass man zum Thema der Frauen macht.
Das ist grotesk. Es ist das Thema der Männer
und dann auch der Frauen. Und ich finde,
wenn man das gemeinsam annimmt
und deswegen haben wir von defizitärer
Männlichkeit gesprochen, die so
was überhaupt macht oder braucht. Und wenn man
das anerkennt und dann den gemeinsamen
Weg skizziert in allen Unterschieden,
dann würde ich mich sehr freuen. Dann hat
auch diese Diskussion bei allen
Unterschiedlichkeiten viel gebracht.
Ich fand die Diskussion, okay,
spannend. Manchmal haben wir, glaube ich nicht
den Bogen geschafft, wirklich
komplett in die gesellschaftliche Tiefe zu gehen.
Also wir hätten wahrscheinlich noch
früher ansetzen müssen bei grundsätzlichen
Debatten. In welchem Umfeld
bewegen wir uns und auch einfach gewisse
Begrifflichkeiten vorher klären
sollen, dann hätten wir wahrscheinlich tiefer
diskutieren können.
Das war so mein Eindruck.
Mich hat gestört, dass diese Diskussion
sehr humorfrei war. Wir leben
in einer Welt, die jungen Mädchen
sind aufgewachsen mit Sex and the City,
sie himmeln die Kardashians an.
Die Kardashians haben die Welt verändert
und sind glaube ich, da meilenweiter
die Kardashians dir als großes Sexsymbol
gelten, glaube ich, würden so eine Debatte
gar nicht führen, weil sie Dekaden weiter
sind. Und ich kann mich mit denen
komischerweise identifizieren,
weil ich auf einen Mann, der mir
diese Einladungen ausspricht, mit Mitleid
herabschauen würde. Falls ihr noch
einen Punkt habt, der heute vielleicht zu kurz
gekommen ist oder der euch wichtig
ist, dann schreibt es gerne in die Kommentare.
Und falls ihr mehr von diesen Diskussionen
sehen wollt, dann könnt ich hier
sehr gerne den Kanal abonnieren. Hier
oben gibt es ein weiteres Video zum Thema
und hier unten ein weiteres Video von 13
Fragen.